you also testified on behalf of your
former partner johnny depp in his recent
libel trial those gestures could have
backfired on you and what made you come
out on their behalf
i believe in the truth and
i believe in fairness and justice
kate moss opens up about her involvement
in the defamation trial between johnny
depp and amber hurd miss moss do you
know johnny depp
yes i do
how do you know mr depp
i had a relationship with him
back in may the british supermodel who
dated the actor between 1994 and 1998
testified in support of her ex during
the trial and now as a guest on the bbc
radio show desert island discs she
explains why she spoke out i believe in
the truth and
i believe in fairness and justice i know
the truth about donny i know he never
kicked me down the stairs
i had to say that truth
yeah that's kate setting the record
straight on a defense tactic used by
amber and her legal team amber alleged
that johnny pushed her sister whitney
down a flight of stairs to support that
claim amber's team alleged johnny did
the same thing to kate years prior i
just
see my little sister with her back
face
her back to the staircase and johnny
swings at her and i don't even
wait
don't even wait
for
any other i don't hesitate i don't wait
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him
but just days later kate took the stand
and cleared the air
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
and during her new interview kate
doubles down i know
the truth about
donny i know he never kicked me down the
stairs
i had to say that truth
even following her appearance on the
stand kate continued to publicly support
her former beau shortly after testifying
kate was spotted at johnny's london
concert with jeff beck since the trial
ended last month and the jury ruled in
johnny's favor his main focus seemingly
music
[Music]
that's the actor showing off his guitar
skills back in june while touring with
jeff
the two also just dropped their new
album together titled 18. when i was a
kid all i dreamed about was becoming a
famous rock star or you know this i
don't know
this great musician
shortly after the verdict was announced
a source told e.t johnny's looking
forward to his future especially his
career he feels like things are on the
upswing for him and like he cleared his
name he's looking forward to the future
both personally and professionally and
feels like he got his career back
[Music]
you